mayville kentucky has woken up to the
most extraordinary devastation
the tornado had ripped through in the
darkness
and with sunrise the loss was so
horribly clear homes businesses and many
lives
there was some warning that the storm
was coming
but it wasn't just one it was a series
of tornadoes
a candle factory with a hundred and ten
people working inside flattened
nearly sixty 000 people are without
power in the state and the number of
deaths is rising
this will be i believe the deadliest
tornado system to ever run through
kentucky now earlier this morning at
about 5 a.m we were
pretty sure that we would have we would
lose over 50 kentuckians i'm now certain
that that number is north of 70. it may
in fact end up exceeding 100
before the day is done
but the destruction has spread far wider
than mayfield dozens of tornadoes have
been reported across six states
one hit an amazon warehouse near saint
louis in illinois
at least two people have died in the
warehouse and dozens are still missing
it has been an awful wait for families
i talked to him about eight o'clock
tonight a little before i texted him and
he was returning to the warehouse to
drop his van off and i haven't heard
from him since i just heard through the
news and we live in edwardsville we lost
power
so i decided to come down here to see
what was going on i had no idea the
building looked that bad and i'm just
i'm worried sick i just want to know if
he's okay you know what happens when you
call a cell phone it just goes straight
to voicemail i mean there's we can't get
a hold of anybody no managers nothing i
i we have no idea what's going on
but amid all this positive news too
dozens have made it out safely
the back corner where i usually check in
and grab my bags and stuff like that
keys for the van all that was caved in
it was a bathroom over there so that
bathroom was gone you just don't even
know who was still in there or who had
passed so it's kind of like it's just a
lot of disbelief
in arkansas a tornado struck a care home
killing one person and trapping 20 more
as the building collapsed this afternoon
the president called it an unimaginable
tragedy officials say the primary
tornado in kentucky was on the ground
for more than 200 miles
the national guard has been deployed in
a state of emergency declared
there are so many communities who've
been hit by this latest extraordinary
weather event hundreds and hundreds in
several states from north to south the
length of the country mark stone sky
news